hello I'm Anne Garin we're going to talk
today about a new book the dictators
handbook which as I understand builds on
work that both of you have done over a
number of years in in in some previous
political science work can you explain
how the dictators handbook is different
from your previous theories about how
dictators and autocracies function
differently than that then democracies
and at whom is this book primarily aimed
well the prior work academic work take
our book the logical political survival
it's 500 page book was about a hundred
and fifty pages of calculus there's no
calculus in this book there are no
statistics in this book there's not even
algebra in this book that's an important
difference there's a little math right
this is a book aimed at an intelligent
politically interested audience people
who read the New York Times The Wall
Street Journal The Economist people like
that the earlier work was aimed at the
three other academics who want to read
150 pages in calculus would that be a
fair description there will be exactly
fair we've tried here to popularize and
translate difficult technical material
into something that's straightforward
and easy to understand because our
arguments are very general they're about
how political organizations how
religious organizations how corporations
how charities how any kind of
organization works and so we needed to
the purpose of this book because we
spend a lot of time talking to students
talking to fellow academics and of
course we never talked about you know
the following function is increasing and
all the calculus terms and we don't give
the statistics all the time we use an
example and we just thought so we
decided to write the book and to be
honest it was a book that wrote itself
it was incredibly easy because we have
this wonderful idea about how politics
works that it's based upon self-interest
and constraints that people have to
operate
in this system you know the jostling of
who's gonna who's going to get their way
and who isn't and it was a book that
would so we just story after story just
fell into place and so we've written it
for a general audience can you explain a
bit more about that theory of
self-interest that goes back to some of
your earlier work is it always the case
that a leader will act primarily in his
or her self-interest trumping every
other absolutely of that that's the
absolute dominant motivation so people
have different things that they would
like to do and if they have some
discretion they may want to advance good
public works projects they may want to
push for some kind of religious
preference over something but they are
the first and foremost you can't do any
of that stuff until you secure yourself
in power and taking care of the people
who keep you in power so that's what has
to be done first so before anything else
people take care of that well we don't
deny that there might be sort of
benevolent people who care about others
first but they're not the ones that
crush the heads that got them to the top
in the first place how far across the
political spectrum does that theory of
paramount the self-interest extent I
mean I can understand in a country in
which there's a cult of personality one
leader who gets to essentially make all
the decisions that that would be an
easier model to sustain than it might be
in a country where say there's a hunter
or going all the way on the other side
where there is a democratically elected
government how far does that so the
theory applies to all governments indeed
to all organizations now what the theory
tells us is that leaders need to obey to
the extent that they can five rules the
problem that they have which is what
you're alluding to is that depending
upon the nature of the political system
the amount of constraints they face and
changing the way the system operates is
greater or lesser
so as we see it leaders want to depend
on as few people as possible to keep
them in power they want those few people
to be drawn from as large a pool of
available people as possible they want
to tax people as much as they can
subject the limitation that they not try
to tax so much that the economy
collapses on their watch and not so much
that they foment a rebellion so there's
an optimal level they want to make sure
to pay those few people they need
properly so that those folks will want
to defect to somebody else not a penny
more and they don't want to make the
mistake of spending money on people who
are not essential to keep them in power
so as we see it a dictator contrasts
with the hood a leader what people think
of as a dictator is somebody who depends
on very few people drawn from a
relatively large pool of people for
example Lenin invented a universal adult
suffrage system in which everybody knew
the elections were rigged but there was
a very small probability for any
individual that they could get into that
little group of insiders it wasn't the
royal family as it had been and they
could get payoffs they could get lots of
benefits as the set of people you depend
on gets bigger bribing people gets to be
too expensive you if you have to bribe a
hundred people not so hard if you have
to bribe ten million people it's better
to start producing effective public
policy it's cheaper than the bribery so
as the coalition that you depend on gets
bigger loyalty to the leader gets weaker
because they're saturating more of the
pool so there's not a lot of substitutes
the quality of policy gets better and
the leader gets thrown out of office
more quickly so a hunt a leader depends
on a small coalition just like a
dictator but a hunt a leader depends on
a small coalition drawn from a small
group for example of generals and a
dictator depends on a small coalition
potentially drawn
a huge coalition so the hunt a leader
doesn't have as much loyalty they get
they face coos and overthrow a much more
frequently than the guy who is the same
little coalition but drawn from a big
pool where everybody knows they're
easily replaced those are an awful lot
of rules
I mean you listed the five main ones but
it it it almost sounds as if a good
durable dictatorship is is is a bit of
an accident of history I mean how could
all of those things so easily be
reproduced in so many countries overseas
not accident of history it in fact one
of our technical papers is about how it
is that some governments evolved to be
democratic and some governments evolved
to be dictatorial or autocratic it's
actually very easy to construct a
dictatorship take an example we use this
analogy in the book suppose we're in a
room of a hundred people and five of us
have guns the five of us are going to
run that rule if nobody else has a gun
so dictatorship creation of dictatorship
is generally about controlling violence
controlling the opportunity to engage in
violence and not being hesitant about
using it democracy is about being very
hesitant to use it because we will throw
the rascals out we we vote with the
ballot box instead of the bullet it's
much harder to construct democracy than
dictatorship well I mean by your model
democracy is a much more self-limiting
operation right I mean you can't you
can't do all of those things over and
over and over and over and over again in
a democracy because as you say oath you
know throw the bums out but it it also
just sort of isn't built that way right
you can't as you say bribe that many
people you can't you can't effectively
run that large and organization if
people keep getting to vote on how that
organization is being run and am i well
we always have to have an executive that
makes decisions so
we have leaders we choose to retain them
if they do the things that we like and
so the basis the theory is what does it
mean to do things that we like and it
turns out things that we like depend
upon how many of us get depicts is the
basis of the argument you know democracy
there's many many people so in the u.s.
to be president you need about 35 34 35
million votes is enough to win the
presidency in a country we might think
of as a democracy but that's the country
of a over 300 million people because not
everybody is eligible and if you can
pick the right votes in the right States
you can win 1/2 the electoral college
seats and that's all you need to win so
it's always a thing to remember is the
president gets more votes than that but
how made is he need and we can sort of
see that Congress at the moment the
debate between the Republicans a
democrat is tailored towards rewarding a
smaller section of society than
rewarding everybody we take the system
down to an even smaller system when
we're talking for example we could go
let's move let's move away from politics
to a moment we talk about a business
enterprise and we might sort of wonder
why is it that Wall Street firms have
been paying out huge bonuses you know
the people are an uproar the people want
these guys they want to rip their livers
out you know these people are feeding
from the public purse to pay big bonuses
and what's the reason here well most
publicly traded corporations they run
like autocracies there's a relatively
small number of board members senior
executives institutional investors you
know often in the tens certainly not
much more than the hundreds who are
really important to staying at the top
so how do you reward a small number of
people while you pay them hugely you
give them enormous bonuses you don't run
them by giving up public goods so we see
that everybody would like to get cut
down the number of people they're
beholden to because that lets them to
give fabulous wealth to those small
numbers of supporters it's that way
for example CEOs and board members get
paid lots of money but so so do college
big you know Big Ten football coaches
right yes the highest-paid government
employee in at the federal level in the
United States is the coach of the
my football team really yes by far it's
not even close Alistar makes a very
important point about democracy so
democratic leaders have the misfortune
of needing a lot of people to support
them but they work as hard as they can
to reduce that number of people so the
Congress is one of the least popular
institutions in the United States and
yet an individual member of Congress has
in an incumbent has a 95% probability of
re-election why is that that's because
the politicians have chosen their voters
the voters are not choosing the
politicians they choose their voters by
gerrymandering they rigged the system so
they don't really have to answer to so
many people and who do they role war but
we have a favorite rhetorical question
journalists would have us believe that
President Obama wants to raise taxes on
the rich and that the Republicans want
to cut benefits to the poor we prefer to
express that differently Obama President
Obama wants to raise taxes on Republican
voters and Republicans want to cut
benefits to Democratic voters because
that doesn't cost their constituents
anything it puts it it helps to enrich
their constituent the expense of the
other guy the subtitle of your book is
why bad behaviors almost always good
politics can you talk a little bit about
perhaps some of the exceptions to to
this overall theory why is it almost
always once in a blue moon and I mean
once in a blue moon it becomes in
everyone's interest to become a more
inclusive society so there's actually a
sort of one of the fascinating things a
slightly one of the harder things to get
the grasp of it is when does the court
want to expand because the court and I'm
thinking sort of the development of
institutions when when did that the
aristocrats when did they go along with
wanting to bring people in and we find
that you know the aristocrats they like
to things they
Hunter's very small concentrated system
but once we get away from that once we
start expanding they actually want to
keep increasing their they want to bring
more and more people in so it's always
in their interest so that the the
leaders nearly always want to contract
society the coalition can go either way
and the people of course who are outside
of the system who aren't privileged they
always want to make the system more and
more democratic more and more inclusive
so relatively few times will leaders
actually ever want to switch from being
in some sense contractionary wanting to
be repressive the few times they're
going to actually have to adopt those
policies is when they're sort of
bankrupt the real problem with running a
repressive society is it doesn't
encourage people do any work if people
don't do any work you can't tax them you
can't pay your cronies so we find a lot
of examples of when we see
liberalisation when politicians actually
do good things they do good things
because they can't pay off their cronies
without doing good things and so they
start to liberalize and we can see you
know the Arab Spring word the lead-up
into getting into those problems was
Egypt's economy was doing very badly an
economy that's based largely on tourism
means you have to have an educated
population sure you start liberalizing
bringing more people in getting people
educated reform carries on now some
leaders managed to sort of get ahead of
the ball and they can just keep
liberalizing enough always so that they
defer the protest so they've given away
enough to the people and eventually a
sort of resource poor country that's
left to its own devices will democratize
so a nice example might be all we talk
about in the book is is Ghana so Jerry
Rawlings comes in he tries to have a
people socialist revolution he's
cracking heads left right and center
he's jacking up army pay to keep them
loyal and then he runs out of money the
country is completely broke years of
dictatorship has destroyed it the coca
crop is gone he goes to the Soviet say I
want to be a socialist give me money
they go wish automate no one will give
him money what did he have to do he had
to turn around to go to the people and
do good things and the people became
empowered eventually he couldn't stop
and make a demand more and more good
things and he delivered more and more
good things he's a leader who in
hindsight looks like the poster boy for
you know liberal economic reform but the
reality was he cracked heads while he
could afford it he only did good things
when he was forced to well then in a way
he actually is a an example of the
entire arc of you theory right I mean it
was in his self-interest to change so he
figured out hmm
how am I gonna stay in power how am I
gonna keep this whole operation running
not the way I did before but the best
way I can do for me right that's why
almost always bad things always do what
will give you the best chance of staying
in power and once in awhile that means
doing good things does you mentioned the
the Arab Spring what did Hosni Mubarak
do wrong he was a oh the dictator for
three decades he ran one of the most
successful countries in the Middle East
bulwark of the US policy in the Mideast
which did some good things like signing
a peace deal with Israel what did he do
wrong okay an excellent question
let me preface this by saying that using
the theory and the dictators handbook on
May the 5th 2010 we predicted in a
public lecture that Hosni Mubarak was
probably gonna be gone in a year okay
okay excellent the first thing he did
wrong he had no control over he got old
dictatorial leaders are in deep trouble
under three conditions to start with
they've just come to power they don't
quite know where the money is
so nobody quite trusts that they're
gonna be paid off properly so they shop
around you survive the first couple of
years you're golden for a long time
until either the Ben Ali problem you are
believed to have a terminal illness this
is what did in Mobutu this is what did
in Marcos this is what did in the Shah
this is what did in Ben Ali or what's
wrong with terminal illness your Kron
No you are no longer a reliable source
of payment in the future or you are very
old very old is a terminal illness and
so they again know you're not so
reliable
so first problem he grew old he's 82
second problem his economy didn't have a
vast amount of natural resource wealth
he depended on two sources of broadly
speaking two sources of wealth one was
for example tourism tourism requires a
relatively well-educated population if
to have a lot of English speakers a lot
of French speakers these are people who
have enough education that they can
think independently and might because
they come together in business
associations begin to organize free
assembly very very very bad for a
dictator so he had the undergirding of
that and foreign aid foreign aid is a
great way to pay off your cronies if
you're not generating an effective
economy President Obama announced when
he promulgated his Afghan policy shortly
after that he announced that he was
cutting foreign aid in Egypt in half
indeed within a few days maybe was two
weeks of his announcement that he was
cutting foreign aid to Egypt in half the
Egyptian Foreign Minister for the first
time since 1979 referred to Israel as
Egypt's enemy and if you were a military
leader you'd be he perhaps sitting there
and thinking well the guy is getting old
and decrepit and he's not able to manage
his relationship with the United States
well enough to keep the money really
flowing most of that money is coming to
we the military leaders now it's getting
cut off
maybe we better look around for somebody
else
maybe we should hedge our bets so now
you're sitting there on the sidelines
one of these relatively well-educated
people unemployed paying double the
price for
dude and you're thinking you know the
military is probably gonna sit on its
hands they can the hedge their bets
because the money's drying up this is
the time to rebel so that that is as we
saw it the the perfect storm in in Egypt
completely consistent with was the
argument in the book that we use to
evaluate that we we had done some
statistical analysis on the countries
that two or three years down the road
back then were most likely to face
regime change
Israel Tunisia Morocco Jordan or near
the top of the list
in fact Egypt was at the top of the list
there was little he could do about the
aging problem you said he did some good
things like peace with Israel as we look
at it peace with Israel was not a policy
he favored it was not a policy and we
could see there very clearly now that
the Egyptian people favored he needed to
have something to sell to the United
States for money right something that we
would value enough to pay a lot for son
of a gun yeah and protect him exactly
and we did for sure we can see a
beautiful expression in this that it's
not a policy that the Egyptian people
were brought along with that we should
love our fellow man across the border
it's you know would the walls on a big
campaign to educate tolerance towards
alternative religion Israel was still on
the grassroots be treated as an enemy
and this is precisely what the
government would want because you can't
if the people actually already like the
Israelis you can't sell we're gonna like
these rallies at a public policy so you
know we don't write books we still write
and we still see Egyptian text books
that say you know the Israelis aren't
good people because we want to encourage
hatred because we can sell that and we
can sort of see that taking us a it is
is not a popular policy so the pew the
Pew Dewar's survey people they do a big
worldwide
Global Studies and there is amazing that
the countries they pick out as the ones
are having the most anti-american
feelings are the ones that get huge
amounts of USA the dictatorial countries
they're not liberal democracies they're
the countries that take enormous amounts
of a to undertake US policies that are
highly unpopular at home so the
Pakistanis they hate the Americans the
Afghans they hate the Americans the
Egyptians they hate the Americans
because we we pay their leader to get
the money to pay off the military to
keep the people down to adopt a policy
that they don't like they should they
should they should be pretty missed to
two things about Egypt in this entire
discussion here we haven't said the
words Tahrir Square that the it is it is
separate and I guess utterly independent
from your theory that of why Egypt was
prime primed to fall and Mubarak was
primed to fall that that there would be
popular demonstrations and I mean that's
not that I think is the the worldwide
idea of why he fell is that quite
separate from the theory so take a step
back and ask yourself why people were
willing to demonstrate and they weren't
willing to demonstrate five years ago
they felt they had license to now right
they had less to lose because things
were going badly in Egypt for them and
they had more to gain because exactly
because the foreign aid was cut in half
they would have had a reason to believe
that they will not face vast amount of
oppression which they would have faced
five years earlier so from the way we
think about this we think about this
from game theory perspective they're
doing what's called a backward induction
your guy on the street you're thinking
do what do I want to demonstrate no I'm
gonna get my head bashed in a little bit
more educated so I want to demonstrate
not this year but oh now I see the
situation is changing the loyalty of the
military has been shaken yeah
maybe maybe they will sit on their hands
the risk of getting my head bashed in is
still there
but it's lower so if it gets low enough
or enough people it's worth it then
others observe gee nothing happened to
these folks the military did not bash
their heads the military even protected
them from the police who did try to bash
their heads more people take to the
streets so it is exactly this
calculation is the leader vulnerable
people would always like to overthrow
dictators the problem that they face is
that most of the time it's a very risky
thing to do when the moment arises they
then they seize that moment well in in
the Egyptian case you identified a few
minutes ago is that the the first to
recognize this and act on it was the
military which is always through the
backbone of the country I and and
certainly was the big part of the reason
Mubarak was able to stay as long as he
was now that the military is nominally
in charge they announced elections for
well there's not more than not only a
charge they are in charge they've
announced elections for November do you
think that the elections will actually
proceed in Egypt or will the military
make second calculation that this
holding pattern is probably better than
the risk of an election the well I think
you're entirely right to say this
holding pattern will continue because we
have an election so we're going to have
elections that are probably unlikely to
be truly meaningful
so there's unlikely to be a large amount
of free press
there's the reinstitution of the sort of
hated martial laws where people picked
up on the streets given short shrift by
the courts and locked up for protesting
so there's not going to be a large-scale
demonstration they're going to use
repression against religious extremists
groups are rising that threaten the
stability so we're not going to see a
particularly fair election one of the
great advantages that we sort of
discussed earlier of having an election
particularly doesn't count for much is
an elections a great way of telling
anybody that they could rise to the top
and anyone can be brought inside the
government
and become a person of importance but
precisely because a lot of people can be
brought in
everyone who's inside can be bought more
cheaply so that's the beauty of actually
holding elections so we're not actually
big believers enforcing elections on
countries where they're not really going
to be meaningful so in some sense you
know Pakistan might have been better
when it continued to be under a military
hunter and both case is the reality was
the leaders beholden to only a small
section of society in one case though
that small section of society doesn't
have replacements so the leader has to
work hard in order to keep in member -
in Musharraf case the army very happy
whereas in you've got an election
doesn't work well it's a substitute
mechanism to keep every let everybody
know that you're easily cut you're
easily replaced and therefore they hope
they'll do the dirty work that you ask
them to do for a smaller amount of money
they're more loyal and I would follow up
on something there that the Musharraf
example okay so here's a guy who
executed a successful military coup
takes over the country and becomes for
his own self-interest a u.s. partner if
not an ally post-911 Biggers otherwise
they're gonna blow up my they're gonna
you know overrun invade my country blow
me up whatever a better thing to do is
to help the Americans go after terrorism
first thing the Americans do after
saying thank you and giving him
gazillions of dollars is to say you have
to take off your uniform and hold
elections was that a strategically poor
choice for the United States because
Musharraf was more useful to us in his
previous role than the current
government is I'm going to answer that
two ways
was it a strategic error for the United
States yes
to politicians in control in the United
States differ from politicians elsewhere
in the world No what do I mean by that
they're interested in what was good for
them and if it happened to be good for
the United States that's terrific
and if it happens not to be good for the
United States but it is good for them
that too is terrific so their
calculation is how do my constituents
respond to this not how does grand
strategy respond to this how does this
affect the country's welfare five years
six years down the road but how do my
constituents react my constituents don't
like our backing military dictator so
they are going to react well to this
therefore I'm going to promote that
policy so sticking with Pakistan for a
bit here there is a popularly elected
government in Pakistan backed by the
military generally assumed to to really
run the show does that model still fit
your theory I mean can you have
essentially a frontman can you have
somebody out there who is the person
with whom the United States deals
directly was our dari in this case who's
mentioned in your book somewhat admiring
Lee for his ability too yes yes perhaps
you could talk a little bit about that
but I mean it is is he a dictator is is
is he because he fit your your your
model well this is the beauty of the
democratic systems that haven't evolved
very well we have elections so we'd like
to think of the classic one man one vote
one person one vote this is the way we
like to think about elections
functioning but in many many cases we
find that people actually implicitly end
up voting in big blocks so for you were
to think of a Pakistan case we go to a
rural area a politician will show up and
they will make an implicit deal with the
village elders but if this village
deliver enough of out
they will get stuffed they won't be
getting much because there are lots of
other people they can buy them for but
they're gonna get a few jobs they're
going to go that way there's going to be
some crumbs are going to go down to that
village
so delivering those votes for a
politician who's almost certainly going
to win in a particular area is going to
get from those few crumbs so people go
along with what the village elder tells
them to do so when we've got people
isolated in these systems politicians
are very good at playing them off we'll
give you a few little things it's not
much but if you don't vote for us we're
going to get elected anyway and you
didn't help us so we're going to give
you nothing so you know during the
floods last year I've worked with a
colleague Alejandra Flores quarrys who's
now at the University of Essex and he
him and I doing that we're looking at
natural disasters and one of the things
we saw was a distribution of aid it was
vastly towards cideries supporters so
the probability of you getting any
assistance greatly increased if you came
from regions that supported parties that
were part of his coalition it came from
the opposition you got nothing
so just literally the simple things that
we think of is handing out blankets are
driven by these politics of buying
things we see the same thing in the u.s.
it turns out handing out federal
disaster aid we can predict which
districts are going to go this has
become a sort of burgeoning part of the
technical literature about you know
where do we distribute FEMA aid and it
turns out elections are just as
important as wind speed but not to the
same extent that it is in Pakistan in
Pakistan there were instances where you
know if we take there if we break the
dam here we can run this water through
this guy's a state into the desert and
save hundreds of villages downes
unfortunate the guy whose land it was
going to go through was a member of the
cabinet and he sort of went up on the
bridge and said this isn't going to
happen so we see bad public policy we
see redistribution we're saving the
futures and even though the system is
nominally democratic now one of the
things that we are hoping to cure people
up with the dictators handbook is the
distinction of categorical regimes
democracy autocracy monarchy Hunta
for instance we talk about this winning
coalition drawn from a pool of people
the selectorate all democracies have the
characteristic that the selectorate is
very large the pool of people and the
winning coalition is relatively large
but highly variable in size in Britain
to control the prime ministership a
candidate in a two-party race needs to
win half of the parliamentary districts
with half of the votes so they only need
25 percent of the vote 75 percent of the
vote
properly distributed could have gone the
other way in the United States we
estimate that you can control the House
the Senate and the presidency with as
little as twenty percent of the vote
what that means is that when you're
doling out rewards you're focused on who
do you absolutely have to have not just
who backs you in other systems you need
much closer to a simple majority of the
vote it it varies all over the place in
Pakistan but you need a very small
percentage of the vote to control the
country I think we estimated somewhere I
don't know the exact number somewhere
around 10%
well that fundamentally changes how much
public good you do and how much
corruption you engage in there gonna be
a lot more corrupt than we are will they
be as corrupt as North Korea no way in
North Korea and Kim Jong Il depends on
maybe 200 people out of almost 20
million people he can be much more
corrupt but sodaro is in a position to
steal a heck of a lot and to allow his
coalition of backers to steal a heck of
a lot that's why they're loyal to him
they're not loyal to him because they
think he has better policy ideas are
loyal to him because he's he's making
sure the blankets go to them and not to
the other person who was flooded who
didn't vote the right way so continuing
the sort of us-centric line of
questioning here just for a minute
what the u.s. now wants from Zardari
and and Pakistan is is two things
basically one keep a lid on terrorism so
it doesn't become a external threat to
the United States whether in Afghanistan
or elsewhere and sort of a subset of
that specifically go after these groups
that that primarily operate along along
the Afghan border is that it neither of
which Pakistan has done fully despite
certain promises so if it is easy to is
it in Zardari's interest to stay in
power to keep the to follow the rules of
dictators handbook to do any of those
things results just before the dictators
handbook I wrote a book called the
prediction years game and the
penultimate chapter of that book is
about how much aid it would take the
United States from the United States to
get the Pakistanis to pursue the Taliban
and so forth it's about one and a half
billion a year and the book makes the
point that for that amount of money
we'll get the optimal effort we
shouldn't expect them to wipe out the
Taliban we shouldn't expect them to wipe
out al Qaeda in Pakistan because if they
do the money will stop we have no reason
to give the money if that's the
objective if they fix the problem as
much as Mubarak did not work hard at
educating Egyptians to love Israel
because the money would stop flowing
so the Zardari government the more
nuanced but there's a very government
was working reasonably hard at tracking
down and killing or capturing Taliban
and al Qaeda leaders in February of 2010
they killed the number two Taliban
leader and so forth so they were
delivering enough to keep the money
flowing now they have an additional
problem we have to recognize and again
it goes back to the theory there's not a
Pakistani leader so Zardari and
has his set of cronies the ISA has its
own interests the rest of the military
has other interests so he has to weave a
coalition together he's not been very
good at getting the ISA is I on board so
then there are questions if so what
would it take to change their behavior
more than were willing to pay because
their longer-term interest is is get us
out of the way and Ally with these guys
well I mean the ice is essentially
operating organizationally the way you
use your layout right I mean they're
they're very sort of irrelevant but
exactly they have to figure out how are
we strategically going to be able to
continue our power base and to be able
to call the shots to the extent possible
in Afghanistan plus oh wait am I gotta
worry about India so they're there
looking out look it up for them you you
talk to me we were talking about Egypt
about the sort of this the gradual
willingness of people to take greater
risk to demonstrate against the
government to you know to go against the
government period how how does that
contrast in Libya where we did see
protests taking place in and wallet and
in Syria now we see protests taking
place in the face of really horrific
government violence that people are
willing to brave right so Libya Libya is
a case where moammar qaddafi
violated one of the five rules that
Bruce went through earlier he made a
classic mistake he actually was too nice
to the people I mean we find that hard
to believe because we live in the United
States where our presidents beholden to
thirty five million people so he's got
to keep a lot of us happy
Moammar Ghadafi didn't have that problem
yet compared to some of his neighbors
he'd been comparatively nice so Libyans
got substantially more education their
neighbors in Tunisia in the Yemen in
Saudi Arabia in Egypt in Jordan
in Syria he didn't meet to educate the
people in some sense he was making a big
error because most of his loyal was
extracted by foreign workers if they
protested he just sends them home and
get some more so we didn't need to
educate the people big mistake to make
2005 of the country I just mentioned he
had the biggest restrictions on press
freedoms by fast our outlier in terms of
how draconian his restrictions were 2010
he was fourth tied down with South
Arabia and very close to cetera all the
others had put in more press
restrictions than him he allowed people
to start to talk and that was a big
problem then we get a little spark and
suddenly people say well the regimes
around us aren't as strong as we thought
so that's more information that they
think maybe it's safe everything's going
wrong and so people took to the streets
he'd given them the opportunity to
organize he hadn't broken enough he
hadn't been smashing in enough heads and
people took this as a sign of weakness
it turned out I don't think he was that
weak but then NATO military stopped him
actually being out of deploy the people
who are willing to break heads he's I
mean you look at him he had phenomenal
loyalty there are still people backing
him even though he he's stuck in remote
towns now but he still has a few bunch
of fanatics supporters who are staying
loyal to the very end
ours is not a happy view of the world
and let's pick up from here you know the
sad thing is I think this has been a
really poorly implemented policy by the
West because the reality is the next
group of leaders are going to come in
they're gonna have unfrozen assets
they're gonna have billions of dollars
pouring in the oil revenues going to
come back in the countries are washed
with weapons you know the people are
going to be fighting to become the bin'
aapa list in terms of power who can buy
the most loyalty get the weapons pointed
at everybody else then from there
they're going to cull out the supporters
they don't really need we're gonna be
back in the same type of system that we
have before we're gonna have a leader
who's gonna be very hard to buy because
it's got a lots of his own wealth and
he's going to be brutal to the people a
different set of people are going to be
persecuted to the people that were
persecuted under
under the former Colonel but I don't see
anything different changing and you know
he made an error
I can't of being too kind it's unlikely
that the next guys gonna make the same
mistake the Syrian case looks quite
different now and indeed we are as Alice
or just said quite pessimistic about the
future of Libya we're optimistic about
the future of Syria there are places
where we're optimists in the Syrian case
so Assad was looking at an economy with
nine percent deficit annually relative
to GDP it's a very big you know we
complain at our they're way way ahead
and so he was facing an economy again
with some educated people unemployed he
has some natural resource wealth that
unlike Libya's was rapidly declining
becoming a smaller and smaller part of
his economy foreign aid to Syria was
slowly drying up so all of the economic
conditions were bad news for him making
the risk more attractive to people he
has been brutal in his response to that
risk people have continued to fight and
because Syria does not have vast natural
resource wealth and if it is also not
flooded with foreign aid when Assad
finally Falls then Syria will probably
become a reasonably liberalized place if
it is flooded with foreign aid out of
good intentions very bad news because
then the new leaders will be in a
position to do the bribery that's
necessary to shore themselves up and
don't need to listen to the people so we
have to hope the foreign aid doesn't
come except after performance benchmarks
are met have free assembly have free
press etc have free speech you can
borrow against promised aid for a year
if you don't get the lump at you if you
meet those conditions you get it
promised again escrowed for the next
year until you're entrenched in free
speech free
press freedom of assembly if you have
those things in place it's really tough
for leaders to be oppressive does so is
your advice then to President Obama that
he not reward any of these governments
to richly that what whatever you know
civilian maybe slightly military
flavored government emergency protection
follow-on to Assad keep your distance
so it's a little bit more complicated I
want to come back to that in general yes
in general one of the big effects
foreign aid is to significantly increase
the probability that an oppressive
dictatorial regime stays in power it has
a significant impact on the survival of
dictators so Egypt is more complicated
because although that remains true the
president has to play that against it's
the impact of hostility towards Israel
on his reelection prospects so basically
as it always comes back to it's not
national interest it's the politicians
interest so in in that case one of two
things has to has to happen we either
are going to have to pay a lot bigger
price to Israel if for example there is
an election and the Muslim Brotherhood
in Egypt oh sorry and the Muslim
Brotherhood in alignment with the
military controls the country the price
of maintaining good relations with
Israel goes way up so we have to decide
will we pay that much higher price is
that worth it in terms of domestic votes
or do we leave it to the Israelis and
others to manage that problem on their
own
my guess is we'll pay the price we only
have a minute left
I'll let you have the last word you've
given a little bit of advice to
President Obama in an article in foreign
policy this month what's the single
worst thing
that President Obama could do in the in
a couple years he's got left
according to again we you you use the
term worst we always want to go back to
the worst for whom are we talking about
the US people as a whole we talking
about for himself
so he could spend all his time and
resources focusing on making the US
great that might not be such a great
policy for him or for the Democrats come
the next election so who we have to you
know buy I want to clarify your question
if he wants do the best for him which is
what we expect he will and what
according to you know the incentives he
has he should be doing he will be trying
to shore up democratic voters so he'll
be trying to make sure that we had
benefits for unions we get more
education for teachers because teachers
and union workers they vote Democratic
how are we going to fund these things
well we want to tax the rich why because
the rich tend to be Republican voters so
we want to bring money in want to
redistribute it out so the best thing
for him would be to focus on making his
supporters the ones he needs as happy as
possible the Republicans of course they
want him out of office so what are they
going to do they're going to try and do
exactly the stuff they're going to cut
the benefits to them we're gonna say we
could say poor but we're gonna say
Democrats and that lets them have tax
breaks for the rich aka the Republicans
I'll stretch but Bruce boy know de
Mesquita thank you very much but both of
you I've really enjoyed the book and I
look forward to having a chance to to
hear more about it as you I guess it
comes out right into the today okay
great well thank you very much thank you
very much